[Musique]
journée marathon ce vendredi 1er octobre
pour le président du département cyrille
melchior qui était en déplacement à
cilaos
propriétaire du site de l'ancien hôtel
des thermes le département souhaité
revaloriser ces deux parcelles un projet
en harmonie avec le site est adapté au
marché local le but combiner l'offre des
termes avec celle de l'hôtel et faire de
cilaos une destination thermale pour les
réunionnais les touristes ici nous
sommes sur un site emblématique de la
réunion il n'y a pas dans tout l'océan
indien ainsi dédiés au thermalisme
et lorsque je vois donc le projet que
vous nous présentez je ne peux que m
la matinée s'est poursuivie au collège
alsace correo cyrille melchior
accompagné du président de la casud
andré thien ah koon ont mis en terre des
plants dans les jardins de
l'établissement
deux fois champion du concours
d'embellissement des collèges alsace
corée a bénéficié de la dotation
biodiversité de la collectivité pour la
création d'un arboretum qui produira des
semences pour le plan un million
d'arbres
dans une autre note collège que notre
collège est beau
et pas parce qu'on vit dans un beau
cadre on entoure et de la nature bah on
aime ça et tu vois là pour convoler
participer au projet autre moment fort
de la visite la signature du pst 2 pour
cilaos par le président du département
et le maire jacques técher donc il est
important pour le président du
département que je suis de rendre visite
à cette commune à ce mr à l'ensemble du
conseil municipal doit à renouveler la
solidarité du département à travers le
pacte de solidarité territoriale qui
nous permet de financer beaucoup de
projets des communes et notamment si
dense mais ça a été cette route qui part
de bras sec jusqu'à l'entrée de la
commune et bien une route qui a coûté
près de deux millions cinq cent mille
euros avec des fonds du département et
nous allons poursuivre dans cette voie
de la solidarité en finançant toujours
et bien c'est un autre projet avec le
nouveau maire jacques richir moi je veux
que la solidarité ne soit pas un mot
qu'on lance comme ça à la légère je veux
une solidarité concrète partager avec de
la co construction et nous avons accordé
une large place à la transition
écologique pense que si la hausse dans
sa biodiversité est une commune aussi
fragile la signature du pst de a été
précédée de l'inauguration du chemin
pente d'abord dans les travaux ont été
financés par le pst 1 à hauteur de 2
millions d'euros
représentant entendu tous les messages
positifs et des encouragements des
usagers
je ne vous cacherai pas mes sentiments
de joie de satisfaction en vous
accueillons ici même souvent ce matin
sur ce site depuis la nuit des temps les
chemins les routes qu'ils soient
terrestres marahoué rien on était une
des priorités pour tous les peuples pour
toutes les civilisations
car les routes vous le savez c'est
l'accessibilité le déplacement des
peuples l'acheminement de matériels
d'animaux de denrées alimentaires et
autres fournitures d'un bout à l'autre
des terres c'est aussi l'économie les
communications les échanges et l'intérêt
général l'ancien site vtt nouvellement
réhabilitée a également été inauguré ce
jour débuter cette année les travaux ont
permis de créer un réseau de neuf
circuits soit au total 53 km qu'il y a
de départ de sentiers donc là on se
montre la route de bras sec et ensuite
deuxième départ de sentiers se retrouve
donc au niveau du plateau des chaînes il
s'agit là de 53 kilomètres de sentiers
praticables en vtt ou en vtt avec
assistance électrique donc accessible à
tous il y a donc neuf parcours de deux
descentes et 7 de cross country pour 53
km de sentiers je vous dirais même 53
km2 bonheur une journée qui s'est
achevée chez une bénéficiaire satisfaite
de son nouveau cadre de vie du
dispositif d'amélioration de l'habitat
mis en oeuvre par le département cancun
est là des personnes âgées nos gramounes
the casbah faut les anciens il faut
améliorer et bien le département à ce
devoir de solidarité en accompagnant ses
personnages et à améliorer leurs cases
ce sont des cases qui date de 30 40 ans
et parfois vous avez là des
malheureusement des toilettes qui ne
sont plus adaptées l'électricité qui
font refaire vous avez des problèmes de
moisissures avec de l'humidité ça met en
danger la place santé de nos gramounes
et donc nouvelle à réhabiliter pas de
4000 logements et là je suis assez loge
chez une dame qui nous a t il m'a montré
les travaux qui ont été faits et bien
les travaux étaient bien fait faut le
dire je suis content l'entreprise a bien
travaillé et bien je suis content aussi
de diacres cette dame maintenant elle
vit dans des meilleures conditions
à cilaos le département participe à
l'amélioration de l'habitat de 300
ménages pour un budget estimé à plus de
2 millions d'euros
[Musique]